alors à qui profiterait à candidature
d'eric zemmour moi j'aurais envie de
répondre à la france tout simplement
pour commencer ce serait un petit peu
partisan en tout cas la politique parce
que je pense qu'il relance le débat
aujourd'hui il rebat les cartes et jeux
pour repréciser la chose je pense pas
qu'ils profiteraient à emmanuel macron
en fait contrairement à ce que disent
les gens c'est à dire que le l'ennemi
juré d' emmanuel macron fallen litres
frd manuel da cruz c'est marine le pen
c'est contre elle qu'il aura envie
d'être au second tour et il m'avait eric
zemmour allait prendre des voix à marine
le pen et peut-être laissé passer la
droite en fait à sa place et dans ce
cas-là macron sera bien plus mauvaise
posture que ce qu'ils imaginent pour moi
eric zemmour il profite d'abord eric
zemmour il est en auto promo permanente
il est là pour vendre son livre faire un
tour de france ensuite je suis assez
d'accord il profite à une refondation de
la droite il est là pour emmener la
droite un peu plus à droite mais je
pense qu'ils profitent quand même aussi
à emmanuel macron pas forcément dans
l'hypothèse d'un second tour mais dans
la capacité kml macron de se poser
finalement en candidat du centre alors
qu'il va faire campagne à droite et
zemmour sera plus à sa droite qui
permettra à emmanuel macron de passer
pour le candidat de la raison